مستجدات الزلزال المدمر في تفاعلكم اليوم
كيف يصمد الناجين بعد اربعه ايام تحت
الانقاض مصابين ودون طعام او ماء ودعوات
لدراسه النموذج الياباني في مواجهه
الزلازل وصور وفيديوهات متداوله ولكن
مضلله اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
حجم الكارثه الكبير اللي بتعيشوا سوريا
وتركيا والتطورات المستجده اليوميه
الزلزال عنوانه موضوع رئيسي ووحيد في
حلقاتنا من ايام ضحايا الزلزال بيزيد يوم
بعد يوم والحصيله اليوم قاربت العشرين الف
قتيل في سوريا وتركيا والاعداد مرشحه
للارتفاع هذا غير عشرات الالاف من الجرحى
والالاف من المفقودين اللي لازالوا تحت
الانقاض وكمان خلال الساعات الماضيه
استمرت الهزات الارتداديه والزلازل عن
تسجيل زلزال في منطقه جنوب تركيا
5.1 وكمان زلزال ثاني تم تسجيله على
الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه شده كانت اربعه
فاصله ثلاثه ويبدو انه اثار الزلزال
والهزات الارتداديه تجاوزت شمالي سوريا
ووصلت الى اطراف العاصمه دمشق وخصوصا في
مدينه حارسا او الانهار فيها ليلا مبنى
مؤلف من اربع طوابق وتسكن في عائلتين وعلى
الرغم من هول الماسه ومرور اربع ايام على
الزلزال لكن في ناس للسجانسه بتطلع من تحت
الانقاض حيه ناس انكتب لها عمر جديد
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على سلامته والله عايشين وطيبين
وما في احسن منه والله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني اللي بنشوفه خلال عمليات الانقاذ على
الرغم من الالم اللي فيه لكن في جانب مفرح
وهو الاطفال والشباب والمسنين اللي جاسمين
بيطلعوهم من تحت الانقاض بعد ايام من
الزلزال وايام معلقين فيها بلا اكل ولا
شرب وكمان نقص فيه الاكسجين ومع ذلك
متمسكين في الحياه وما زالوا احياء
الخبراء الانجاسين بيقولوا انه مع مرور
الوقت فرص العثور على ناجين طبعا بتقل لكن
رغم ذلك ممكن للسيده يلاقوناجين وهذا
الشيء بياخذنا السؤال المهم كيف في ناس
رغم اصابتها ورغم ايام من غير اكل وشرب
وتصمت تحت الانقاض هل في ظروف معينه مثلا
بتضمن صموتهم عبر سكايب شمال سوريا مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري الخوض البيضاء
الرائد صالح اهلا فيك معنا ويعطيكم
العافيه على جهودكم اذا في البدايه ممكن
توضح لنا بشكل عام قدي ايش مده استمرار
عمليات البحث
عن الناجين يعني
تحياتي لك ولساده المشاهدين حقيقه موضوع
البحث عن الناجين يعني مستمر الى الان منذ
بدايه الزلزال
وصل عدد الناجين الزلزال الذين تم
استخراجهم
وعدد الاشخاص الذين استخرجناهم فقدوا
حياتهم
1950 الان
مثل ما قالوا الخبراء يعني اكيد هذا
الموضوع هو معروف للكل انه نحن فعليا هلا
يعني صار شبه الامل معدوم انه نلاقي ناجين
تحت الانقاب بسبب انه صار فتره طويله على
الزلزال
يعني تنتقل للفرق لعمليات انتشال الجسد هو
كل يوم كان هناك انتشال جثث للضحايا
وستستمر يعني العمليه ممكن عده ايام اخرى
لحتى ننتهي من الاعمال بشكل كامل انتهينا
من بعض مواقع
ادلب المدينه مدينه ادلب وجسر الشغور
والملاند والرمادي كونها كانت يعني اقل
ضررا المؤمن ودانه وسرمدا كونها قاعد اقل
ضرب باقي المناطق كجنديرس وحارم وسلقين
وبسنه وعزمارين وهذه المناطق حقيقه يعني
العمل مستمر الى الان موجوده نحن في كافه
المناطق غطيناها بنسبه مئه بالمئه لم يعد
هناك منطقه واحده متضرره من
الثجيب لها كفرق دفاع مدني بس هل في لا
زالت مثلا يعني خلينا نقول قرى صغيره او
اماكن لسه ما وصل طولها
تم الوصول حقيقه اول ما بدانا عمليات
البحث والانقاذ
ركزنا على الاماكن الكبيره وبعدها يعني
استنفرنا كافه فرقنا الموجوده بشمال سوريا
واستجبنا لكافه القرى الصغيره
دقيقتين وتم انهاء الاعمال ولكن حقيقه
الرابعه صباحا تفاجانا في امر انه في احد
ان النظام السوري افتتح سد الرستن بشكل
كامل وهذا ما سبب ارتفاع لمنسوب المياه في
نهر العاصي وادى الى اغراق مخيم وقريه
بلول على الحدود السوريه التركيه
استجبنا لها في الساعه الرابعه صباحا من
هذا اليوم
واخلينا المدنيين من المناطق ولم يتضرر
احد ولم يكن هناك
العمل الفيديوهات اللي بتوثق عمليات
الانقاذ يعني ماليه المواقع والشاشات شيء
وصراحه لحظات يعني مؤثره وسعيده بس السؤال
كمان اللي يسالوه الناس انه كيف بيتم او
انه كيف هدول الناس تمكنوا من البقاء
احياء خلال الاربعاء ايام وهم تحت الانقاض
يعني
فعليا لا يستطيع احد البقاء حي تحت
الانقاذ الا اذا يعني حقيقه هي قدره الهيه
يعني لمده اربع بعد اربع ايام تكون الامل
معدوم لكن بالثلاثه ايام الاولى هناك
الانسان يستطيع ان يصمد فتره بين الزمن
يعني اذا كان لديه اكسجين بشكل كافي ونحن
فعليا عندما نسمع اي صوت في اي مكان اول
شيء ممكن يعمله فريق الدفاع المدني هو
تزويد هذا الشخص بالاكسجين يتم تجين
وتزويد وكان اذا حقيقه احتاج ايضا الى اذا
راينا بانه جسمه ضعيف فنعطي له سيروم حتى
يستطيع ان يستعيد صحته قبل ان يتم عمليه
الانتشار لانه ممكن بعد ان نجده يكون هناك
عم قتل باطونيه او امور اخرى تعيق وحقيقه
كون الفتره الزمنيه التي حدث بها الزلزال
كانت الناس كلها نائمه
فكثير حقيقه من الاشخاص الذين استطعنا
انقاذهم بسبب حمايتهم من قبل الاشخاص معهم
يعني
معظم الاطفال الذين انقذناهم وهذا يعني
حقيقه مناظر مؤثره ومبكيه هم كانوا في حضن
ابائهم او في حضن امهاتهم كانوا يحمونهم
من الزلزال فكانوا هم الضحيه ونجى الطفل
من هذه العمليات هناك بعض الاطفال الذين
نجوا فقدوا كل عائلاتهم لم يبقى احد من
عائلاتهم لذلك يعني عمليه الانقاز هي
دائما تاخذ وقت طويل يعني انت بعض
طفلي في مدينه حارم اول البارحه انقذنا في
في الساعه تقريبا 7:00 صباحا حتى تم
استخراجها من تحت الانقاض ولكن عمليه
الاستخراج استغرقت 16 ساعه كامله تقريبا
من العمل لا نستطيع يعني نحن عندما نكون
هناك بعض الصعوبات والعوائق الكبيره التي
واجهتنا بها
حيث انه لا يوجد مخططات سكنيه لهذه
المباني فنحن لا نعرف لا نعلم ان المطبخ
لا نعلم اين غرف النوم لا نعلم اين
الصالون فكان عندما تجد شخص
على قيد الحياه تحت المبنى ونستخرجه كاننا
حقيقه هو كنز هو كنز ليس فقط غاذه هو كنز
من المعلومات هو يعطينا المعلومات الكامله
اين يتواجد الاهالي ان يتواجد اين ينامون
في اي مكان يستريحون في هذا الوقت هذا
يعطينا حقيقه سرعه في الاستجابه سرعه في
الوصول في الضحايا
يعني صراحه يعطيكم العافيه او كل فيديو
بيطلع وخصوصا الفيديوهات اللي بتنشروها
على حساباتكم يعني بتحيي فينا الامل ويعني
فعلا بنشعر بالتاثر وخصوصا النقطه اللي
قلتها انه كثير من الاهالي حمو باجسادهم
ابنائهم وعشان كذا الابناء الصغار تمكنوا
من
النجاح في سؤال بس بعض الناس كانوا
بيسالوه على مواقع التواصل انه ما بتعطوا
لما بيكون الشخص لا زال تحت الانقاض ما
بتعطوا له ماء او اكل او اي شيء من هذا
القبيل بتستنوا تطلعوا اول
ما ما ابدا ما بنقدر نعطي ماء لانه نحن ما
بنعرف حالته صحيه يعني اذا تشرح لنا هذه
النقطه
يعني نحن لا نستطيع الماء هو خطير جدا في
هذه الحاله يمكن ان لا نعلم هو عدم قدرته
ممكن نعطيه بعض الماء حتى نمسح به فمه
ولكن لا نكتبهما تحت الانقاذ حتى الاكل
يعني ممكن نعطي قسم من بسكوتي ولا يمكن ان
اعطائك يعني شيء له علاقه سكريات خفيفه
حتى لا الجسم لا يعني اذا كانت فارغه حتى
نحن الناس الذين لسنا تحت الانقاذ اذا
بقينا يومين بدون طعام وجئنا اكلنا بشكل
مفاجئ فتحدث لدينا اضطرابات جسديه فكيف
الشخص المصاب لذلك لا يمكن يعني اذا كان
الشخص بحاجه الى
او بحاجه الى الى
طاقه فنعطي يتم ربط سيروم يتم فتح وريد
واعطاء سيروم ملحي او سكر حتى يستطيع ان
الفكره
نحن بنشكرك ويعطيكم العافيه وعلى كل
جهودكم وان شاء الله المزيد من الاخبار
المفرحه كان معنا عبر سكايب من شمال سوريا
مدير الدفاع المدني السوري الخوض البيضاء
رائد الصالح شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الزلزال اللي صار والدمار الكبير اللي
خلفه وفتح كلام ونقاش كثير عن العمران في
المنطقه وطريقته وفي ناس حتى اشعلت
انتقادات لما اعتبرت انه استهتاروا اسلوب
بناء غير امن وناس كثيره امام هذا النقاش
صارت تقول شوفوا اليابان احسن مثال ليه
لانه اليابان من الدول اللي بتقع على خط
الحزام الناري وهذه منطقه زلازل وبراكين
ولمن تعرضت لزلازل كثيره ومنها مدمره
تعلمت من التجربه واتبعت اسلوب عمراني
بيخفف الاضرار والناس الان شغاله بتقول
انه يا جماعه تعالوا نتعلم من تجربه
اليابان ايش هي بالضبط تجربه اليابان وكيف
بتخفف من الاضرار خلونا نعرف من مختص اللي
بينضم الينا من عمان المهندس المعماري
والباحث في اداره المخاطر يزن محادين اهلا
فيك معانا اول شيء خلينا يعني احاول اعرف
منك بس متى بدا اليابانيين في اعتماد هذا
النمط الجديد او الاسلوب الجديد في البناء
اهلا فيك اول شيء خلينا نرجع بالتاريخ شوي
لوراء بال 1923 في واحد تسعه ضرب زلزال
كبير اليابان
140 الف شخص بهذا الوقت وبعد بالحرب
العالميه الثانيه بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بال 1946
بلشت تعمل في قانون جديد ومعايير تصميميه
للمنشات وهذا القانون تطور بعد فتره
بال1968 وال 1981 وبعدين بال2011 كل ما
يصير زلزال بصير في هناك تطور على هذه
المعايير وعلى القوانين البناء اللي في
ايش الاختلافات الان يعني لما نجي ننظر
على مباني اليابان في بناءها ايش المختلف
عن المباني في الدول الاخرى
عباره عن اسطوانات هيدروليه بتتمدد يعني
بتتمدد وبتنكمش مع التمايل البنايه طيب
يعني يعني هي بيبنوها بطريقه بحيث لما
يصير الزلزال تميل ولكن ما تسقط ولا تتهد
طيب هذا الشيء لما بداوا اعتماد هذا
الاسلوب هل فعلا تم او قله الاضرار من
الزلازل
نعم في
من خلال بحث العلمي في كمان شغله مهمه
عملتها اليابان اليابان عملت سرقه مليار
دولار على نظام انذار زلزالي مبكر بحيث
انه بتبعت الارم سيستم للناس قبل 80 ثانيه
من وصول الزلزال وصار هذا الحكي بال 2018
وبال11 واذا بنيجي على التاريخ بنشوف كيف
المباني يعني بال 2011 المباني اتضررت
بشكل كبير بسبب تسونامي بس في مباني ظلت
راكزه وفي نفس الشيء بال20018 في احد
المدن ضرب زلزال فقدوا خمسه اشخاص و500
جنيه تقريبا
والقطارات
وطرق البناء كانت والثواني التحذيريه اللي
قبل الزلزال كانت كفيله يعني بتغيير
الكثير وتقليل الاعداد وحتى طريقه البناء
اللي بتقول عليها طيب الان اذا هي تجربه
اثبتت نجاحها على الاقل في
الحجم الخسائر واهم شيء طبعا الخسائر
البشريه نحن هنا بنتكلم عنها الناس جالسه
بتتكلم انه لازم الحكومات تتبع هذا
الاسلوب في البناء او انه ليش لازم
تستفيدوا من تجربه اليابان او هكذا وهكذا
وهكذا وفي لون مثلا في سوريا وتركيا وما
الى ذلك الى اي درجه هذا اللوم واقعي
والله اول شيء حسب يعني دوله زي اليابان
هي بتصرف مليارات الدولارات على البحث
العلمي على التكنولوجيا والحلول المبتكره
زي ما حكيت صرفك مليار دولار على النظام
زلزالي ومبكر بالاضافه انه حمايه الارواح
والممتلكات والامكانات الاقتصاديه شغله لا
تسمى فاحنا علينا بالقراءه دراسه التاريخ
دراسه كل منطقه بحد ذاتها وين موجوده
موجوده على السطح او صفائح الكترونيه او
كل هذا دراسات احنا كمهندسين معماريين
نتشارك مع المهندسين انشائيين ومع كل
الخبراء والعلماء دائما مشان نطور اساليب
البحث العلمي تبعتنا
ونحاول نساعد دولنا دول
طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه
التوضيحات كان معنا من عمان المهندس
المعماري والباحث في اداره المخاطر يزن
محادين شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
مع السلامه
مع السلامه يا دار اهلين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وين اهلين لك وينكم يا جيراني
وين العلم
[موسيقى]
البحث اظهر ان الفيديو من اثار قصف روسيا
على ريف ادلب من زمان وحتى الصوت مو جزء
من الفيديو وانما مركب عليه تركيب طيب هذه
الصوره كمان اللي راح تشوفوها الان
مشاهدينا تم تداولها وقيل انها لعناصر
اردنيين بيشاركوا في انقاذ ضحايا في
اللاذقيه في سوريا لكن الحقيقه ان الصوره
تعود اغسطس الماضي هي من عمليه انقاذ شابه
عشرينيه وقعت من مرتفع صخري في منطقه
البحر الميت في كمان صوره الكلب اللي
بجانب يد تحت الانقاض طلعت كمان مو لزلزال
تركي وسوريا ومو معروف بالضبط تاريخها
يعود لمتى لكنه موجوده على موقع
الشهير للصور سوره
الطفل هذه برضو اتضح انها مو من تركيا ولا
من سوريا وانما مصورها اوكراني وموجوده
ايضا على عدد او مواقع عديده للصور والان
متداوله على انها جديده ونفس الشيء ينطبق
على صوره المسن هذا اللي خلفه وشاي الخبز
وبرضو لقوها على مواقع عديده للصور وحقيقه
انها من تركيا وانما من زلزال سنه 99
واللي كان مدمر هذه الصور كمان لمنزل مدمر
طلعت مو صحيحه والحقيقه انها من تركيا
فعليا ولاثار زلزال فعلا شرق البلاد لكنها
من سنه 20 20 ولا علاقه لها بالزلزال
المدمر الاخير
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقتنا
لليوم والاسبوع تفاعلكم يعود والقاكم
الاحد على امل ان تكون الاخبار الاسبوع
الجاي اسعد او على الاقل اخف قسوه في امان
الله
[موسيقى]